previously on TV scoffs what are you
doing I'm suturing a banana now you
never ever want to do this with a
pineapple I almost died episode does not
contain a couch gag as clever and
intelligent as the humor can be on The
Simpsons they have never shied away from
sitcom II humor such as running into
something with their car that could
easily be avoided and all I'm saying is
maybe they should also with what appears
to be six feet and Counting of snow on
the ground why is the school still
having this event at all and before you
say Oh
Minnesota and I had to go to school with
ten feet of snow on the ground just
remember that when snow days come up in
this very series they often require very
little snow to close cool show sets up
earlier that they will be stuffing jokes
onto every sign and into every corner of
The Simpsons universe with puns wordplay
irony hyperbole and every other trick in
the thesaurus and if you think this
isn't gonna earn a bunch of cents off
you haven't been paying attention to
what goes on around these parts also
let's assume the misspelling of pageants
on purpose there is no one who would
write a star rating like that and unless
that's the British Way of writing four
and a half stars to which I say deep foo
is been to the nine Bob nope and even if
I don't know manion's I'm still got to
go to spare idiot box at stadium-- books
I guess despite not having any risers
each row of these kids appears to be
higher than the previous based on their
feet either that floor or super slanty
or those kids be levitating main
characters in a sitcom are always
forgetful and late to their children's
functions cliche
[Music]
an early Simpsons was so hard up for
cash that when these kids clearly open
their mouths for a no sound it came as a
neat and considering animated characters
never age she could be a second grader
well into her 40s oh wow the reactions
of the parents to Lisa's dance are
exactly like their reactions to Ralph's
eyeball popping out earlier like
impossibly so also this grass skirt is
so sparse that I'm just gonna believe
that Lisa nude row here is simply
wearing yellow tights and move on for
the sake of all of us okay
Marge has absolutely no reaction to Bart
getting pulled out of the choir
I guess early on Marge was blind not
only to her son's antics but his
punishment to friends and family
Christmas letter narration literation
why is Homer surprised to you there's
not a snowball to stance and met
gradings hell that he didn't see or hear
that cat before pulling her up with the
Christmas lights for someone who just
left a Homer sized dent in the snow he
somehow has no snow on it he must have
the Bill Murray Ghostbusters Cool Whip
Claus Marge turn on Jews if the lights
were already finished what was Homer
adjusting on the side of the roof when
he fell also while The Simpsons is
already showing many many bright spots
early dan Castellaneta is terrible
Walter Matthau impression does not
appear to be one of them you'd like it
all clinics it's a simple routine
involving lasers cool however it is
rather expensive of all the things
they're going to cost the Simpsons their
Merry Christmas it's decided that Bart's
tattoo removal was important enough to
spend all their money off all because
Marge thinks homers getting a Christmas
bonus at the nuclear plant I guess that
means mr. burns was a completely
different character who actually gave
out Christmas bonuses in previous years
this couldn't wait Oh ow quit it I could
swear Bart is saying I'll quit it before
Lisa actually touches his bandage on Fox
large thinks it's necessary to turn over
the jar so that Homer can see there's no
money in there despite the nature of the
jar which is glass also what exactly is
the floor plan for The Simpsons home
looks like the arch from the living room
is directly across from the arch to the
kitchen but earlier it looked like the
arch was much bigger and under the TV
area perpendicular to the kitchen who
designed this home MC Escher damn Homer
I know Christmas is ruined but isn't it
snowing outside and you're in short
sleeves he probably is drunk so maybe
that's the reason but damn the emotion
of homers fraud I see here knowing that
his family doesn't have any money for
Christmas but he can't tell them is
actually genuinely moving even if the
show somehow runs for 30 seasons
it's nice to know that it will never
lose sight of that heart for extra cheap
laughs so blind that will never happen
mr. Simpson you've got two port
chocolates well Happy Holidays Simpson
hey Flanders wasn't a religious
do-gooder yet when they were making the
show but having Flanders say Happy
Holidays is against his character type
how many Santas could possibly be needed
in one small city Oh Cupid Donna
addiction throwing out that always
hilarious Donna Dixon reference for all
the bosom buddies and dr. Detroit heads
out there huh wait wasn't she also in
Wayne's World
exit to Eden were alliterative titles in
a freaking contract if Homer is using a
chainsaw to cut down his illegal
Christmas tree why does the stump look
like this this guy and his dogs are not
very good at protecting their property
if they can't chase down Homer Simpson
running with a large Christmas tree also
is there even a tree tied onto this car
or did homers stuff it in the backseat
or the trunk
considering how Homer dragged it away in
the amount of transportation to get back
to the house someone would be excellent
at TV since not unless you have
bloodhound bloodhound in your
bloodstream you could only hear those
gunshots a bit in the distance so Homer
was nowhere near any gunpowder man there
was less than zero percent chance Bart
wouldn't know this was his father before
pulling off the beat sure gambling
establishments might be open but dog
racing on Christmas Eve when it's
freezing
I've heard of some degenerate gambling
in my time but this tops anything
Michael Jordan has ever done Fox cashes
in by putting some Star Wars in my
Simpsons what's next Homer saying I find
your lack of faith disturbing come on
boy sometimes your faith is all that
keeps me going
but I guess TVs betrayed me doesn't seem
possible that someone stole the TV
Siddons motto almost 30 years ago but
here we are
damn Barney's making that hundred and
thirty dollars stretch a long way and
why did he even come back to the dog
track did Homer tell him that he'd be
looking for winning tickets out in the
parking lot while Barney went out got
his hair done and got a date wasn't Sam
as a little helper a replacement for
some other dog in that race did this guy
really think he had a chance to win yeah
well thank God he didn't because now the
Simpsons can get their iconic dogs but
he's a loser
but that egg eat listen damn it someone
cutting dusty onions in come on Simpsons
if you're gonna finish with an episode
ends with a camera shot
freezes the action for maximum emotion
cliche at least have the moment the
picture is taken look something like the
final shot oh do you think that because
people assume you're doing Santa you can
just get away with anything
[Music]
home we've been singing this whole song
correctly the whole time but when Marge
asked him to take it
he becomes enrico pallazzo child abuse
hurts no wonder no one came to my
birthday party
excuse me seen up and down Cleveland
Street the symbol of the old man's
victory all right the mob
[Music]
you'll shoot your eye out kid
I'm Cali old st. Nick oh yeah we'll just
see about wow you sit on a throne of
lies